desde muito pequeno eu gosto de desenhar
pegava um lápis uma caneta ou que
tivesse e passava horas desenhando
desenhava de tudo também figuras
abstratas plantas pessoas eram um
passatempo para mim naquela época
certo dia eu sentei para desenhar minha
mãe é uma mulher muito bonita e para
fazer isso eu peguei uma caixa de giz de
cera com 12 cores
eu acho que são 67 anos à época comecei
esse bendito desenho e e aquele cor de
pele da caixinha sabe que na verdade é
um beijo bem rosado para pintar o corpo
dela e essa nomenclatura cor de pele dá
outro ted kennedy também o amarelo por
atingir os cabelos e na hora dos olhos
eu não sabia que como utilizar e aí
perguntei muito que a teor do que corro
vejo azul
ela até então não sabia que eu estava
desenhando olhou meio confuso assim o
papel deu de ombros e respondeu tanto
faz
esse aqui é o desenho e essa minha mãe
uma mulher da pele preta dos cabelos
escuros dos olhos negros mas tão negros
que mais parecem um abacate bem maduro
eu não sabia mas naquela época minha
percepção do belo já estava danificada
pelo racismo
muito tempo se passou desde então entrei
na faculdade de jornalismo
comecei a estudar todos os efeitos que
as informações causam na gente e hoje
depois de formado eu consigo compreender
e visualizar como se dá a construção de
um imaginário que associa diretamente a
pele clara cabelos lisos e os traços
finos a beldade
quando comecei a me interessar por
beleza eu consumia muito sobre o assunto
foi a revistas acessava sites blogs
portais
mas era uma beleza branca uma beleza que
não representava
e durante muito tempo eu achava que
aquilo não nos pertencia por falta
justamente de representatividade para
aquele jovem tássia um com pouquíssimas
referências positivas da negritude
habilita tinha que ser apresentada
exatamente da maneira como eu havia
desenhado
infelizmente essa não foi só uma
experiência foi a mesma experiência de
gerações que cresceram não se enxergando
na grande mídia aquela que
cuidadosamente nos excluía dos espaços
de apreciação e foi com sede de
representatividade que eu decidi criar o
meu próprio veículo de comunicação o
herdeiro da beleza enquanto comunicólogo
eu sabia que seria muito difícil romper
e exterminar com um padrão de beleza
eurocêntrico que sobrevoa a nossa
sociedade já tem alguns séculos já disse
a ele que tinha aí não precisa romper
com nada mas vamos criar outros
e aqui eu quero enfatizar o plural vamos
divulgar outros rostos que também
merecem ser enaltecidos rostos
multiétnicos cujos sócios hoje e tardios
o meu propósito desde o início foi
promover um debate sobre beleza e
repensar o papel da maquiagem
principalmente o da maquiagem para a
pele negra
esse caminho que eu decidi percorrer
hoje avaliar a cultura através da
maquiagem foi um caminho muito difícil
confesso porque primeiro eu me deparei
com uma mídia que não inspirava ou
talvez tenha inspirado pela culatra
segundo com o mercado que não reconhecia
o potencial consumidor de nossa
comunidade negra então por exemplo era
quase impossível escrever uma boa
matéria é recomendando sugerindo uma boa
base para a pele negra há pouquíssimo
tempo desceram com uma péssima
experiência que algumas mulheres negras
tinham com maquiagem eu aposto que vocês
conhecem alguma que saiu traumatizada do
salão porque ficou cinza por quê
branca porque ficou laranja porque ficou
vermelha tem olha que se identificou já
vindo aqui com respeito mas vamos
colocar somente a culpa nos cosméticos
não porque até hoje eu diria que os
profissionais também não estão bem
treinados
teve uma vez que eu estava num salão e
tive a oportunidade de assistir o dia de
beleza que uma moça tinha ganhado e ela
tem um tom de pele mais escura do que o
meu
ela bem frustrada quando terminar a
maquiagem se olhou no espelho e falou
exatamente assim tá vindo porque não
gosto de minha pele ela não assenta
maquiagem e quarto e último ponto que eu
tive que enfrentar nessa minha jornada
foi a reprodução insana de técnicas
racistas de maquiagem foi e ainda é
muito comum a gente encontrar nos cursos
nas oficinas ou até mesmo nos tutoriais
na internet dicas e truques para afinar
os nossos narizes
ou seja há no ar através da maquiagem um
importante símbolo de nossa estética foi
fomentando essas discussões que o
herdeiro da beleza se tornou referência
na internet e fora dela também é muito
mais do que um perfil no instagram ou um
canal no youtube é uma comunidade de
resistência
pessoas do mundo todo se mostram
inteiramente dispostas a se envolverem
com a minha voz com a minha mensagem com
essa mudança gradual um que busca
reconhecer e valorizar a beleza negra
os reflexos dessa idéia eu já consigo
perceber mas antes de apresentar alguns
comentários aqui eu queria provocar
vocês perguntando vocês já pararam para
pensar já se imaginaram se privando de
sorrir em uma foto porque o cenário é
muito grande
alguém aqui já fez isso alguma vez o
esse comentário diz o seguinte estación
as fotos de suas maquiagens me fizeram
repensar muito preconceito que eu tinha
com o meu nariz
ele é o nariz largo e quando eu abro
aquele sorriso ele fica maior ainda
nunca tinha tirado uma foto
rindo porque achava feio depois que você
entrou na minha vida e conseguir pela
primeira vez mostrar uma foto sorrindo
muito obrigada
legal né esse outro comentário diz a
sintaxe eu amo seu trabalho mostrando
seu último vídeo a reunião hoje aqui na
empresa
decidimos nos reposicionar no mercado e
herdeira da beleza com certeza motivou
essa mudança
esse comentário recebido uma grande
companhia de cosméticos aqui no brasil
uma das maiores obras responsabilidade e
esse último é tão profundo em sua
simplicidade do que eu poderia passar
horas aqui discutindo sobre ele
obrigada por me fazer acreditar que eu
posso ser bonita
legal né gente receba esse feedback
são com esses comentários que eu
finalizo dizendo que a busca pela
valorização da estética negra é um
complemento fundamental na luta
anti-racista ea maquiagem é uma
ferramenta importantíssima
jamais pensei que isso é futilidade
muito obrigado